avec nous le père de l'est là annie
fernandez dieu orgue et fernandez
bonsoir monsieur fernandez
bonsoir ça va bien me disent ça va bien
vous très bien merci
je vous imagine au volant de votre
voiture pendant le match r parce que
vous étiez pas à flushing meadow
j'ai dû faire un accident quoi
oui l'entreprise je suggère fortement
à tous les téléspectateurs ne jamais
faire cela écoutez un match de tennis en
même temps
qu'est ce qu'elle a
votre fille qui fait que l ébloui
maintenant temps que ce qu'est ce
qu'elle a de particulier
bon c'est une question plus compliqué
parce qu'elle a beaucoup de chose de
particulier bien sûr je sais c'est ma
fille et c'est ma joueuse donc pour moi
c'est un diamant unis diamant unique
je pense qu'au bout de la ligne c'est
ensuite on le pense et on essaie de
vraiment choisir un adjectif ou une
qualité si sa persévérance elle est une
fille depuis qu'elle est petite elle
n'abandonne jamais elle percevait le
personnel à chaque défi qu'on place en
avant d'elle l iq loi mais c'est cette
persévérance de caractère et de
mentalité quels acquis et qui nous
laisse croire que l'impossible est
possible
parlez moi de passer au tennis vous
savez qu'il ya des exemples de parent
qui ont voulu trop pousser leurs enfants
qui voulaient soit par procuration peu
importe pourquoi voulez pousser trop
leurs enfants ça devenait malsain
parlez-moi de à quel âge on se dit oh là
elle a vraiment du talent faut quand
même la poussée parce qu'à pourra aller
très loin l' équilibre entre le jeu et
la joute
bon c'est une excellente question je
pense qu'on doit définir au commencement
la différence entre le récréatif et le
haut niveau et le récréatif pour moi
c'est simplement ça c'est de la
récréation on n'a pas besoin de pousser
dans quand on est con on est dans un
système récréatif si l'enfant est dans
un niveau de haute performance on doit
commencer à les pousser des du début
mais d'une façon
très contrôlée d'une façon que ça
demande un petit peu plus deux mais ce
n'est pas dans un sens où ça ou c'est
une impossibilité l'enfant commence à
souffrir
mais c'est c'est toujours très important
à chaque groupe d'âge d'abord toujours
des défis pour que l'enfant puisse
apprendre à être un combattant sur le
terrain ainsi que logiquement
émotionnellement le physique c'est très
facile parce que ça joue mais c'est deux
autres aspects où on doit commencer à
initier un petit peu plus en détail à
chaque groupe d'âge
c'est intéressant parce que vous parlez
du d'un combat effectivement entraîner
c'est un combat pour les seuls puis à
l'adversaire devant nous
mais il ya là il ya le plaisir de jouer
ce qui me frappe chez votre fille c'est
qu'elle sourit c'est très rare on voit
qu'elle aime ce sport là
oui absolument elle adore le sport est
là dedans cependant le don de la voie de
la raquette dans sa main mon père en
fait quand il ya longtemps quand il l'a
vu jouer pour la première fois et me
disais voyons dont salaire que la
requête et fait partie de son bras de la
maniaque
qu'elle soutenait la raquette et et elle
est regardée sur la quête proche de 2
dans sa chambre c'était quelque chose de
monde impressionnant parce que des des
deux
d'un jeune âge il voulait toujours les
abords de la raquette dans la main et je
pense que mes nerfs elle elle commence à
comprendre qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en terminant en quelques secondes vous
la voyez aller jusqu'où
numéro un
je dois prendre à elle c'est aussi
simple que ça jusqu'à date tous les
défis qu'on a mis qu'on a mis en avant
d'elle je ne sais on se gratte la tête
on se demande des questions puis à la
con elle continue à nous surprendre donc
pourquoi arrêter maintenant
alors guy fernandez père et entraîneur
qu entraîneur devrait jirs de lille
annie fernandez qui jouera demain en
quart du finale à new york ce
exceptionnel merci beaucoup de nous
avoir par m merci à vous